what is going on there citizens of the
reject nation we got ourselves a new
trailer for she-hulk attorney at law you
guys excited i actually am yes yeah i
hear this is fun like a 30-minute
episode comedies and stuff but i feel
like it's still going to be important
integral to the mcu you excited andrew
the character you know is uh really uh
funny has a lot of depth to it so yeah
i'm curious to see and fascinated what
they uh come up with for this show don't
fold your arms at the thought of that
anyway guys smash hulk smash that like
button also uh subscribe and click that
notification bell for anything else we
cover um and hey let's get to it there's
nothing more to say
[Music]
oh god
[Music]
wow jeez what the hell man still in
control no overwhelming feelings of rage
no a normal amount of rage you do revert
back to gen 4 when you sleep was the air
horn really necessary for comedy
absolutely
this is a multi-year journey you're
about to embark on
yeah who's your best friend nikki
spandex spandex
being a hulk asks for balance
wowie not bad you have so much more to
learn
yes
so i'm clearly nailing it at all these
things
[Music]
if you want to go back to life as a
lawyer i i respect that he doesn't mean
that
oh yeah
breaking the fourth wall
more and more eccentric superhumans are
coming out of the woodwork
[ __ ] we're going to launch a division
for them and i want the she-hulk to be
the face of
jennifer wallace got it got it okay
i have a serious conflict of interest
this man tried to kill my cousin bruce
yeah that's quite all right oh
people only care because i'm
representing emil blonsky i think they
care because they're like hey that
girl's green
do your thing good i really like this
outfit
yeah
i'm not proud of this
our walters is on the edge of a
precipice
oh yeah
we do things by the book
the bulk of the shanty no
american
uh loss
you like it or not you're now a
superhero
let's do this
[Music]
you know that friend you had in high
school
who was way cooler than you were
attracted got all the attention from
everyone yes i know that friend
hello
i think i'm jealous is that what i'm
feeling
i wonder if it will not be blurred in
the actual episode about to say that
yeah
it's the new phase
there he is
[Applause]
i've heard someone else for a second
in the show where it would make the most
sense to have them meet in the courtroom
they meet out on the streets
yes yes yes oh god
oh my god i'm light-headed now i've been
waiting for a clear shot of frog this
whole time i felt this emotional
experience just happened when we just
went
it's terrible
and then the immediate dissatisfaction
of where's my frog man a lot of things
confirmed here in this one trailer you
know and it's funny that we haven't
really gotten much the main villain you
see like peaks of her who's the actress
playing titanium jamila jameel i heard
great things about her this looks like a
lot of fun but you know like we talked
about the previous show there's things
to definitely talk about in this one
trailer right now but andrew what do you
think i thought the cgi was definitely
improved from the first trailer so that
looked great i really was digging the
comedy i love the interactions between
hulk and jennifer i mean just you can
tell there's that that family history so
i was really enjoying that i think the
thing i really enjoyed the most about
this trailer was breaking the fourth
wall i really enjoyed that aspect of it
because that's a big thing in the comics
with the characters before dared excuse
me
before deadpool she was breaking the
fourth wall so i'm glad that they're
incorporating that in the series i mean
yeah this just looks like a lot of fun
it looks funny too and it was really
cool again seeing emil blonsky turn into
abomination i thought maybe they were
gonna take it because they're breaking
the fourth wall and i thought maybe they
were gonna go meta for a second maybe
we're gonna see that and say man uh hulk
looks a little different than this one
he uh he doesn't look like edward norton
anymore or something but uh yeah but uh
i don't know
yeah i'd love to see her but i mean she
literally has not come back since
incredible home and there's been a high
demand
for more betty ross bring her back i
could see jennifer's lifestyle kind of
influencing you know bruce banner's
lifestyle a little bit because she's
trying to have this splice of normalcy
while also being this big green creature
and also them being a superhero i feel
like we're gonna get more cameos than
this you know like there was rumors
about possibly the thing appearing in
this show and i kind of wrote it off but
the fact that they teased us with this
much already you know confirming
daredevil's appearance you know i know
at the marvel panel they have revealed
that daredevil born again is happening
we're getting so much daredevil now it's
kind of crazy just we're getting so much
daredevil another thing i've come to
expect it's a positive reaction from no
way home just everyone's seeing charlie
cox on screen i think they're like okay
we gotta like run with this such a
demand for him and now he's and like the
look at the new suit like it's a black
and crisp it looks more like i'm curious
to see the falafel and i hope they don't
unveil it until the actual episode yeah
and the chemistry of mark ruffalo looks
pretty solid like the cgi is still like
wonky at times of course just with the
situation at marvel but uh and it felt
like a lot of times in the like oh you
set them here so that way you could
really mask them with the green
background i get what was going on here
so you could try to hide some of this
but the setup of like everything with
emil blonsky seems so obvious that they
are using this to set up into
thunderbolts it just seems like if
that's the direction they're headed
we're probably going to see julia louis
dreyfus val character show up in this
series and this is also explaining the
whole thing with shanghai and with you
know seeing wong and abomination
fighting each other so we're building up
to something really cool here but i know
you've been excited for this show quite
a bit jon so did this trailer just make
you that much i like this one more than
the first one yeah this gave me a lot of
things i really enjoyed and started to
look forward to and i got caught up in
them sort of one at a time so when it
would change it was a nice surprise and
i love that camara taj or at least
adjacent you know satellites of that
seem to be the new station for like are
you a woman struggling with your new
powers we're gonna help you out yeah but
you know i really love just the uh back
and forth dynamic that it looked like
they were drawing between her and mark
ruffalo the real like familial bonding
that looks like will come of that and
will also dive into just what it's like
to have their powers and she's described
this story as being kind of atypical of
a normal hero's journey or origin and
things like that she doesn't want the
power or she is at least at odds with it
and so i really loved that aspect and
then yeah the breaks the fourth wall and
things that make it look like it's
convincingly going to channel other
things that are a little more bridget
jonesy or sex in the city-ish at first i
was expecting maybe like a a an
anthological thing where every episode
there's a new character and they
probably have a few but it seems like
yeah emil blonsky and abomination will
be sort of a probably main through line
here and i was like that's cool too
because that has grown in a rewarding
way over time that's a piece of
connectivity that looks like it'll lead
to other things like thunderbolts but
it's interesting in and of itself and so
yeah it had the fan service the comic
book things that i was hoping for it had
just the film style things i was hoping
for and it looks really charming so i'm
super psyched one other thing too i like
that this trailer was uh showing that
she's dealing with possibly this
newfound fame as a superhero how is she
gonna deal with that and you know having
her cousin there as someone who's hey
i've been dealing with this for years
it's going to be an interesting thing
you know because we're probably going to
see a situation where she has self-doubt
and sure you know she loses herself at
some point and loses some self-esteem if
you will even at some point so it's
going to be interesting to see how they
play with that character-wise i know you
always liked me for a good little
reference uh one thing i did see from a
visual reference perspective i used to
watch the 1981 uh incredible hulk uh
animated show i was a huge fan of that
and in the titles they would always show
uh bruce banner uh trying to be he's
been trying to be saved by betty ross
and he's stuck in a room where he's
about to be literally closed off and you
see that test that bruce banner is
putting her through with the spike thing
that's about to close her off and she
turns into the hulk because very similar
visual shot to that so cool throw that
out there i like that you pointed that
out buddy all right guys well um i like
that trailer quite a bit i thought the
first trailer really set up our
character and a good tone and you got
even more of that here but now it's like
with the fact of the law firm that she
is now working for and then she's gonna
be representing supers and stuff like
that i just feel like uh we're gonna get
so many more cameos and [ __ ] so yeah
subscribe click that bell leave a like
tell us your thoughts down below on what
you like most about this trailer
adelia chamberlain adelia man it's
another comican
and you are a marvel
that's the segway i've chosen today but
you know what
there's been an eventful time lately i
was thinking just the other day about
the end of the showdown and then i
started to think about the time that we
met we hung out we traded quips and
trivia and observations about how
awkward it is to be in a big room full
of a bunch of people given the time and
place that we're in right anyway
i love you dear and i hope you're doing
well and i hope that you are excited
about the things coming out of this
weekend as excited as i hope we will be
soon as we shoot these reactions
love you be well